Absolutely not.
These are complex issues that have
technical components,
technological components,
scientific components to their solution,
but none of these things happen if we
don't have the understanding through
society what needs to be done if we
don't have the political and uh,
and national well to take the steps that
we have to take if we don't innovate in
the way in which we organize work as
well as organized science and
technology.
It all has to work together.
And I'd like to believe that despite the
fact that we look at these things and
look at globalization as daunting
problems,
they're really terrific opportunities.
And at this point in time,
no nation on the face of the globe has a
better hand to play in the United
States.
Uh,
because we are still the best,
uh,
particularly at the cutting edge and
science and technology.
We're dramatically challenged by other
countries as we should be.
We're still the best and unlike much of
the world,
we build what we do on these remarkable
substrates of a diverse population and a
democracy and a,
uh,
an open market system.
I believe we've got the best
possibilities in the world of helping to
resolve these problems and providing
leadership and having prosperity in the
future,
but we can't do it if we don't have the
core science and technology.
If we don't have young men and women,
whether they're going to be signed,
the stress engineers or not.
If we don't have young men and women who
have some technological literacy,
some quantitative skills,
some understanding of the world at
large,
then we're going to be in trouble.
But the basic answer to your question is
technology alone can never solve these
large scale problems.
On the other hand,
we can't solve them without it.